[Musique]
je suis véronique morel
j'ai 54 ans je suis ingénieur de
formation et je vais vous expliquer
aujourd'hui qu'elle fut mon chemin pour
arriver à l'économie circulaire alors
depuis l'âge de 14 ans je rêvais de
devenir ingénieur
alors je me suis accroché pour faire des
études j'ai décroché polytechnique et
puis ensuite j'ai choisi délibérément
l'industrie pour relever le challenge
d'une femme ingénieur dans un monde qui
était à l'époque encore très masculin
j'entre en tant qu ingénieur calcul dans
le monde automobile chez psa en 1990 je
fais un parcours varié
je vais citer les projets expérience
très structurante pour moi parce que ça
vous fait vivre dans un total esprit d
équipe
et puis à la fin la voiture à la fin
votre projet vous pouvez dire c'est ma
voiture j'ai aussi un parcours dans le
domaine des achats dans la supply chain
des véhicules c'est-à-dire la partie qui
livrent toutes les voitures peu jour par
exemple jusqu aux concessionnaires
partout dans le monde
et puis en 2014 j'arrive à la stratégie
des véhicules utilitaires et des
véhicules électriques
alors au fond depuis ce temps là je me
tourne vers des objets plus
écologiquement responsable à l'époque
tout le monde dans l'entreprise pense
puissance et diesel moi je pense plutôt
confort du client
et puis je me questionne quand même sur
ces fameux véhicules électriques mais
finalement je me rassure puisque les
études montrent que du puits à la roue
et bien le bilan carbone est plus
intéressant que le les véhicules
classiques et puis parce que au fond de
moi je me dis qu'il faut non seulement
proposer des voitures mais aussi
transformer toute la chaîne
à l'époque à vrai dire on
c'est pas concevoir des voitures
électriques en tout cas chez psa
c'est beaucoup plus cher ça va forcément
impacter le client et il va falloir
trouver des solutions
challenge après 4 on me dit d'aller
faire un tour dans les pièces de
rechange en économie circulaire ma
conscience me dis il ya vraiment quelque
chose à faire
mais alors comment vais-je me prendre
alors je m'intéresse évidemment et puis
oui je constate que même dans les études
automobile les tendances sociétales sont
là alors à partir de là deux éléments
man in on est tous concernés et
personnellement j'en ai marre du carl
bashing ambiant alors au fond je vais
déroulée ma méthode traditionnelle
yat il a marché eh bien oui oh surprise
les constructeurs n'ont pas idée du
nombre d'acteurs qui travaillent déjà
la rénovation des pièces sur le marché
mondial on pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui 20
milliards d'euros
donc c'est possible le deuxième point
c'est que les études montrent clairement
un gain en fabrication par rapport à une
pièce neuve on gagne 80 % de matière et
50% d'énergie intéressant et puis quand
je visite les garagistes je vois tout ce
qui se jette et je me dis aussi que les
véhicules électriques arrivent sur le
marché et là on ne va pas jeter des
batteries à la fois onéreuse et aussi
polluante deuxième motivation
par contre la qualité que je trouve
lorsque je visite des rénovateurs de
pièces n'est pas tout à fait au rendez
vous d'un constructeur
alors là je me dis bah j'ai quelque
chose à faire à montrer je vais pouvoir
certifier la qualité des pièces et puis
enfin quatrième élément de ma méthode
traditionnelle
il faut de la rentabilité pour que
l'entreprise
vive les vous le comprendrez alors
finalement c'est bien
me voilà avec quelque chose qui tient la
route c'est un vrai business
il faut tout faire de la conception
achats dustrit yale et surtout vente
ça fait du bien à la planète c'est très
concret et c'est un vrai challenge
alors aujourd'hui où j'en suis et bien
je suis une adepte de l'économie dans
mon domaine j'ai construit quatre airs
avant de recycler et bien nous tôt je
donne une deuxième vie aux pièces
automobiles par l'heureux manufacturing
la réparation rippert ou le reuse ça
veut dire quoi concrètement le riz
manufacturing c'est prendre une pièce
usagers
chez les garagistes au lieu de l'acheter
de la reprendre de la repasser dans un
process industriel total alors là on
démonte tout on lave tout on vérifie
tout je recycle les composants qui sont
évidemment défectueux je remplace par
des composants neufs jeu réassemble le
tout et je teste exemple d'un moteur
l'autre catégorie c leur hyper hyper and
return c'est similaire sahara passe
également dans des ateliers spécialisés
c'est plus adapté aux pièces
électroniques par exemple une radio on
vous prélève la radio qui est défectueux
sur votre voiture
on va la réparer et puis quelques jours
plus tard vous récupérez votre radio
avec vos configurations personnel et
puis enfin le we use c'est quoi et bien
c'est de l'occasion au lieu de broyé ou
rappelé recycler une voiture qui est
totalement irréparable qui par exemple a
subi un choc avant et bien en fait on
peut démonter quelques pièces des feux
arrière un pare chocs pour et bien que
ce soit des pièces qu'ils soient
réutilisables pour la réparation d'une
autre voiture
c'est maintenant plus de 200 personnes
au total qui travaillent avec moi dans
l'économie circulaire
dont 25 qui sont dans mon équipe direct
et qui ont la même motivation que moi
tous âges
on a fait auditer les gains matière sur
les pièces qu'on propose et les gains
d'énergie
on y est on est capable de vérifier la
qualité nos pièces on y est vous voyez
ces pièces-là sur les sur les photos
elles ont tout à fait l'air neuf et bien
oui c'est ça les pièces remanufacturées
pas beaucoup de différence avec une
pièce non mais il ya encore du monde à
convaincre trois types de personnes à
convaincre les ingénieurs parce que les
ingénieurs conçoivent mais ne conçoivent
pas pour une deuxième vie pour
reconcevoir derrière en tout cas pas
totalement encore à mon goût la deuxième
catégorie c'est le garagiste
écoutez quoi qu'on en dise les
garagistes change assez lentement leurs
habitudes
et puis enfin le client final préfère au
fond pour sa propre voiture
encore une pièce de alors pour conclure
je voudrais vous proposer un
questionnement vous qui allez être des
futurs ingénieurs sous la forme de
quatre questions qu'est-ce que je peux
faire moi pour préserver mon futur et
celui des générations suivantes
qu'est-ce que je peux faire moi qui vais
rentrer en conception quelque part ou en
production
qu'est ce que je vais faire pour penser
à concevoir à fabriquer mais aussi dans
l'esprit de refabriquer derrière pour
donner un deuxième cycle de vie à la
matière avant qu'elle ne soit vous
rappelez royer repasser dans des process
de fabrication pièces neuves est ce que
je vais faire aussi tout ce que je fais
là ça sert à quelqu'un ça sert à mon
client
je vais produire si ou ça est ce que ma
clientèle est intéressé et enfin si ma
clientèle est intéressé est-ce que mais
voilà est ce que ça fait de la
rentabilité pour mon entreprise c'est ce
que mon autre
va vivre avec ça alors pour terminer je
voudrais vous partager une petite touche
personnelle
premièrement quand j'ai pris cette
fameuse mission d'économie circulaire à
faire d'étonnantes par rapport à mon
parcours précédents assez classique
automobile
mes filles qui ont à peu près votre âge
on dit waouh ça va être quoi exactement
et puis régulièrement questionnement est
ce que est ce que ça fait vraiment du
bien la planète
encore maintenant deux ans deux ans et
demi plus tard j'ai encore régulièrement
des questions team challenge
non seulement les clients mais à la
maison et puis le deuxième point que je
voulais partager avec vous c'est que
j'espère vous avoir transmis mon
enthousiasme dans le domaine même si
c'est pas tous les jours très drôle pour
moi ce que convaincre réussir les
cahiers des charges tout ça c'est pas
simple tous les jours
aujourd'hui vous et moi nous vivons une
période particulièrement complexe avec
cette fameuse crise pandémique et
sanitaires et économiques
donc c'est pas drôle tous les jours mais
moi je voudrais partager encore une fois
mon optimisme
je suis sûr qu'avec un peu d'optimisme
un peu d'espoir un peu de travail et
chacun une pierre à l'édifice
nous allons tous réussir je vous
remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]